faut savoir qu'après les Césars il y a
toujours une fête aux Fouquets et en
fait en sortant des Césars donc j'avais
César et puis on allait aux Phuket et
puis je dis au chauffeur monsieur je
peux vous demander quelque chose j'ose
pas depuis tout à l'heure mais est-ce
qu'on peut faire juste un détour par
chez moi il y a toutes mes amies
d'enfance qu'on regardait le la
cérémonie et je veux juste aller les
voir et en fait elles sont toutes
descendues elles étaient en pyjama
on dormait tout à la maison et on a crié
dans la rue et c'était merveilleux parce
que parce que le pas ne pas le partager
avec elle c'était donc c'était mon
groupe d'amis depuis que je suis toute
petite et après elles m'ont rejoint la
fête ouais elle a fait